the primary principle the samurai should
keep in mind during daily life is during
a state of order you should consider and
prepare for war
and in a time of disorder you should
think for the best way to bring about
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
forget the following to aid loyal
devotion wives and children treasure and
properties your body and your life do
not forget the following to aid loyal
devotion determination in loyalty the
name of your family parents and
ancestors
for a bushi it is essential to
comprehend the following primary
principle as you have been born a
samurai
you must understand the difficulty of
devoting and sacrificing yourself for
righteousness and loyalty and you must
value your name highly the truth is that
samurai just like everyone else have a
fear of death however if your
understanding deepens it is not so
difficult to enter death it is possible
to die from illness drowning fire to be
killed in a moment of rage or even
through lust even humble towns folk and
farmers can die such a death of course
for those born into a military family it
is natural to die upon the field of
battle therefore if you are prepared in
full for any destiny be it glorious or
ignominiously a few are determined upon
the above primary principle then be
aware that to die is not such a
difficult act keep reminding your wife
children and other family members of the
position that you hold and that all are
indebted to the Lord and if the Lord
should order so you must sacrifice our
lives to expunge this debt
tools for daily use a katana a longsword
wakizashi a short sword as mentioned
previously it is desirable that they are
well sharpened so they can cut with ease
and that they have to rivets items that
should be kept on your person
a quick rope a set square a stone pencil
gold and silver a mirror tweezers a comb
a cloth to clean a katana blade powder
to clean a katana blade a sword rivet to
remove her medicine for sudden illness
and breathlessness beard for a person or
horse a fire striker a wooden taper one
or two sheets of paper for the writing
of oaths be prepared like this when
traveling and even during normal times
although houses grand plans reception
halls and entrances can all be
constructed according to individual
preference samurai do not need to have
splendid residences this is because they
may die for loyalty at any moment and it
is wrong minded to spend a lot of gold
and silver on your homestead with the
intent of securing a future of a hundred
years however if you have an enemy or
someone who has targeted you for
vengeance and wishes to murder you then
if your Lord has ordered that you should
survive and you must cherish your life a
carefully constructed house may be
required used as a strategy to kill your
enemies constructing an elaborate house
will cause them to underestimate you
apart from cases where a use of tactics
is required
most normal samurai do not have
elaborate houses that being said having
a well-designed appearance is desirable
know that merchants and farmers tend to
have luxurious houses for the need of
family business
there are a few things to be aware of
when constructing a garden
do not worry too much about tasteful
design or creating handsome views a
master should make sure that the
greenery and landscaping have benefits
within their layout in terms of defense
it is often the case that gardens are
unsafe if they have been designed with
too much emphasis on creating beautiful
views furthermore there are a lot of
things to be aware of concerning both
the doors and the paper sliding doors of
bedrooms among other things when
entertaining guests is a host keep the
following in mind if the guests start to
fight unexpectedly make sure to settle
the situation so that no one is injured
and that the grudge's do not fall
however when samurai argue do not take
one side over the other and do not to
judge which is right and which is wrong
if one side is judged is correct and the
other is not correct then the side
judged is incorrect may lose face and
have then forced into peace this may
result in them returning to kill their
adversary later on if present when
rumors or malicious gossip about certain
people are being spread then it is
desirable to be very discreet and talk
with care generally those who gossip and
pass on rumors about others are cowards
if being questioned or asked to confirm
what has been said they will often quote
examples of other people's faults and
state that they did this or they did
that this is because they lack dignity
even though samurai may sometimes change
their words at a later date in order to
present an excuse for a misdeed they
should never pass blame on to others for
those actions improve yourself by
considering the above points and know
that you should never speak of others
behind their backs if you do say
anything about someone behind their back
then you should repeat those words to
their face also know that those who talk
to you about people behind their backs
will talk about you when you are not
with them
when attending a dinner give compliments
on the dishes served even if you don't
like them when there are samurai among
your associates who are ignorant turned
stupid and tall can behave without
thinking it is essential to keep your
distance and know that it is a huge
mistake to trick or make fun of them as
they are stupid they may suddenly
threaten to kill you for the smallest of
reasons
there was once a case where an ignorant
samurai took offense and despite efforts
to persuade him that he had taken the
situation wrongly he would not listen
and killed the person he thought had
insulted him if you are unaware of a
person's stupidity then it cannot be
helped but if you are aware of it and
still have dealings with this person
then you are also to be considered
stupid in this world there are many
tales of people who have come across
mysterious monsters when they've been
walking alone at night
however they are most likely invented
from my childhood I have heard various
stories of this kind and have dared to
walk alone in the middle of the night in
the places that are rumored to be
frequented by monsters but I've never
encountered anything mysterious that
being said it is difficult to conclude
that they really are fake just because I
have not seen one even if you actually
experienced such things it is still hard
for samurai to talk about supernatural
beings with any certainty the people who
claim to have seen a monster usually say
that it happened when they were out late
at night on their own or with one other
person on a deserted street this would
suggest that monsters fear large numbers
of people but if monsters truly existed
surely they would show themselves to any
number of people if a samurai believes
he has seen a monster he should be
reserved in this matter and not talk too
much about it to others
during an earthquake immediately opened
the doors and paper sliding doors and
get outside however if you panic and are
too eager to get outside you might
injure yourself on the other hand not
being fast enough
is negligent being crushed and killed by
a house is a dog's death so exit quickly
the way to walk in an emergency is
called a shiiin AMI
this involves concentrating on the big
toe if all of a sudden an insane person
enters through your gate send him back
to his parents or brothers generally
speaking if you talk gently to those who
are insane giving them an impression of
timidity their insanity will become more
intense this also applies to people who
are violently drunk sometimes the person
may be one who has been possessed by fox
but know that these people will not
fight those skilled in our school Hui
means anything that happens unexpectedly
for example fires earthquakes rainstorms
gales thunder storms blizzards floods
fights attacks by group of thieves
people running you in madness people
coming to you for sanctuary and people
who have collapsed on the street there
are more than can be listed here however
in any unexpected situation it is most
likely that you will become confused
therefore the first thing to do is to
settle your mind before dealing with the
situation at hand if you are unaware of
this more often than not you will lose
the initiative because you will feel
rushed therefore always calm your mind
and be prepared for this type of
situation this is a key aspect of our
school
since old times there have been three
places to which a kudu grass is
administered the first is in the
windpipe the second is in the solar
plexus or or around the heart the third
is in the lower leg if no good grass is
given it is like a death offered by
townsfolk or farmers to cut is
undesirable while to not cut his
virtuous never shy away from an act of
virtue
however if two samurai have drawn their
swords and are about to fight sometimes
they cannot just sheath them when
lending either of your swords say the
following
this cuts extremely well therefore you
must use it for a trial cut never just
say I will lend this to you without
mentioning trial cuts place horse
droppings inside some paper and wipe it
over a blade that has been used to cut
someone this will leave traces of the
wiping and the blood will no longer be
seen if there are no horse droppings
available to wiper blade with use the
back of your straw sandals or soil
inside paper this way is good because it
oils the blade if you do not use this
method you will notice a deterioration
in cutting here Moochie mono means to be
sent to someone at the request of a Lord
to inform the person of his crime and
then to kill him however as he is a
samurai he may fight back
therefore there are points to keep in
mind so as not to fail to make the kill
with extreme rapidity inform the person
of his crime then immediately strike and
finish him only afterwards should you
say out loud and for this reason the
Lord has asked me to kill you if you
think that you have to explain yourself
in fold beforehand it may end in the
opponent drawing his sword and fighting
back as well this may be taking place at
the criminals home be aware that his
servants and retainers may join in the
fight also whatever the circumstances do
not say the phrase do you remember that
you did commit until after you have
struck it is not good to say beforehand
and then fail to kill the target
even the smallest amount of crimson
blood will look like there has been
great bloodshed and if you are not used
to this the stench of the blood will
knock you sick and turn you pale
something which is inappropriate for a
samurai because it suggests cowardice
young samurai should accustom themselves
to the stench of blood by taking any
opportunity to observe executions and
punishments otherwise they may be
reputed as squeamish around blood and
therefore unsuited for bloody deeds
[Music]
when you inform your servants that an
order for war gives a specific date for
departure remind them that your fief was
given by the Lord that their bodies and
lives are maintained through this and
that repayment can be given during
battle if they forget this relationship
and flee leaving the Lord's service then
make sure that they understand it is
equivalent to living as cattle or a
horse also tell them if this happens
they will be searched for across all the
lands and then executed and that if they
have fathers mothers and children that
they will to face this punishment as
often as a hundred times a day the two
sides may face off and look as if
they're about to start fighting do not
be alarmed at this both sides with
advance and the ashigaru will move into
position and shoot their muskets but
more often than not close combat will
not ensue however from the moment you
step away from home you should never
drop your guard sometimes it will seem
as if the battle is never going to begin
but events can turn quickly and combat
may break out at any moment it is also
said that within three days after taking
up a position volleys of bullets will be
shot therefore do not become flustered
by this an army may fire off a volley of
paper bullets to show that it has a
large number of muskets in addition
there will be lots of noise such as the
cries of those on night duty and also
goading war cries this may unsettle the
inexperienced
both sides will face off in formation
which will be followed by an exchange of
musket and arrow fire between the
ashigaru after which the ashigaru from
both sides will peel off to the left and
right at this point the samurai will
dismount and form a body of men and rush
to the advanced warriors from both sides
will work their way to face each other
this stage is called the yari bun the
field of Spears she Russia taking
evidence of who has been killed
this includes taking the head of an
enemy soldier after the enemy has been
put to rest and chase down if the enemy
is prestigious take his longsword
short sword or banner as proof and as a
way to discover his name improper heads
these are also called Shira Miku be lice
heads an improper head is one that has
been cut without witness and brought
after the book of heads has been closed
these may be presented by samurai who
have failed to make a kill and take a
head during actual combat the truth will
be that they have found someone who has
had difficulty in escaping and it was
been left behind by his allies they take
this person's head and display it so
that people will take note this is the
act of a coward however if they have
managed to find to capture and behead a
good enemy warrior who was hiding with
tactics then this is not a cowardly act
but should be regarded as an achievement
noses taken from heads in the confusion
of a large battle without a witness to
verify the act are considered to be on
no Kuby possible female heads such a
head cannot be properly judged it could
be that of an ally a monk or a woman
good bushi do not engage in such actions
this involves taking the head of an
injured person of lesser importance and
pairing it with a helmet that is
left behind by a different fleeing enemy
discovered heads these are also called
chiku be death heads if there has been a
large battle or even a skirmish both
allies and enemies may be injured and
died brave warriors tend to leave their
kills so they can move on to kill more
enemies sometimes other people take
these abandoned heads when you have
taken an enemy head in battle people may
approach you as if they are offering to
help but instead they snatch the head
and run away with it when presenting a
head hold it with your right hand while
putting your left hand on the cut of the
neck allow the Lord Commander to glimpse
the right cheek of the head and then
withdraw to the left do not kneel down
the person presenting the head should
not look at the face of the lord
commander but instead focus on the head
itself the following types of head
should not be offered for inspection
heads with their eyes and mouth open
malignant heads with flesh blood or such
using from the cut heads with their
tongues protruding these are called a
Yushin no Kuby malignant heads and are
not the preferred type for those with
their eyes open pull out the eyelashes
and tap the eyes with the handle of your
great sword at this they will close for
those with protruding tongues force the
tongue back in malignant heads differ
from other heads taken in battle as they
sparkle with moisture and have an
intense look in their eyes as if they
were still alive
[Music]
upon returning from a successful
campaign with your reputation enhanced
you should hold a celebration just as
you did at the departure for war in such
a celebration all family members
including wives and children should be
gathered together to engage in a
drinking party achievements that
servants have attained should be
examined and rewarded accordingly if any
of your servants were killed during the
war track down their offspring and
compensate them warfare is more
dangerous than treading on thin ice
in order to see into a deep pool
therefore if you return with success and
have gained achievement know that you
have unified with heavens principle and
truly have been blessed by the gods
[Music]
you